hey David what is the most corrupt thing
you have personally experienced most of
it has happened in Argentina where I was
born I mean listen we're in the United
States I've been involved in a lot of
corrupt stuff when I went to college the
entire textbook scam where you need the
latest 17th edition because the problems
are all on different pages so you've got
to go and spend 150 or 200 bucks on a
textbook instead of 30 for a used one or
whatever that is an absolute and totally
corrupt scam our health care system is
an absolute and totally corrupt scam
remember last year I had an appendectomy
I pay I was paying last year for 21 a
month for my health insurance I still
had a $2,000 deductible I still had a
separate copay for the emergency room
right I mean I was paying for 21 a month
and still owed 3 grand for my
appendectomy and I have what's
considered pretty good insurance all of
you know the healthcare system is a
total corrupt mess the contract for my
gym memberships is traditionally pretty
damn corrupt where you need you know
notarized sealed in blood paper letters
sent to who-knows-where if you want to
cancel your membership signing up is
super easy if you want to cancel the
membership it's pretty damn difficult
but really the most corrupt stuff I've
personally experienced all relates to
Argentina Argentina has a problem with
corruption of different kinds and I'm
talking more official corruption right
in Argentina I've had situations where
family members needed certain documents
they needed some document related to
their schooling my dad's high school or
who knows what and you you basically
just have to pay a bribe now is it
called abut if everybody does it and
it's just expected is it a bribe or is
it just sort of a gift I mean I don't
know but payoffs kickbacks all of this
stuff and I know that there are people
who are very politically partisan in
Argentina who will say that only happens
under you know Parana stood
ministrations or Kirchner wristed
administration's or the neocon Maquis
admit it happens all the time ok this
has been going on in Argentina since I
lived there when I was a kid
it's been going on through the entire
time I lived in the United States it's
gone on through every type of
a lot of the stuff you hear about in the
u.s. you know bribes for various
licensing if you want to get some permit
to do some construction or whatever in
the US it's sort of a big deal like you
hear you know maybe a bribe would work
but a lot of times you would try it and
it would be like it would implode you
would get reported for the bribe you
might be prosecuted whatever in the
Uniting Argentina it's just common and a
really common phrase this might be
interesting to some of you if you want
to I'm gonna translate this and though
in the way I think makes the most sense
if you are open to paying a bribe and
you suspect a bribe may help you but you
don't want to be too obvious about it if
you get pulled over by the police and
they start detaining you and hassling
you if you are given a runaround about
oh no in order to get this stamp you're
going to need this and this and this and
this the phrase you can use to suss out
whether there might be a payable bribe
is you know this really is an
inconvenience is there some other way we
might be able to take care of this right
now that's the code word and I don't
believe this is unique to Argentina
that's been a phrase that I am aware of
having been used in other Latin American
countries as well is there some other
way we could take care of this right now
is the sort of approved implicitly
approved way to explore whether there's
a bribe that could pay to get out of
something or to get something done and
if the answer is yes you will get one
type of answer if the answer is no the
person you ask it to will just look at
you and say what are you talking about
no you need to get this paperwork gained
or you need to get this notarized or
whatever the case may be a lesson from
Argentinian corruption not unique to
Argentina but that's where I have
probably experienced the highest degree
of of corrupt stuff we've got a great
bonus show for you today it is Friday
meaning producer Pat handles the bonus
show I will be back on Monday with a new
show and a new bonus show